the owner of a website devoted to the
area 51 military base wants to know why
federal agents busted down the doors to
search two of his homes so he says there
were actually two teams of more than a
dozen agents serving Federal search
warrants at two locations on November
3rd but the target of the Warren says no
one will tell him what was done or why
the search was even authorized news now
Chief investigator George Knapp now with
the exclusive story
secrecy has always been Paramount at
Area 51 a once obscure Outpost in the
Nevada desert that might be the world's
best known secret base and it's very
isolation is of the greatest importance
since the mid-1950s Groom Lake has been
the location of choice for the testing
and development of America's most
advanced military technology including
spy planes drones and Cutting Edge
sensor systems Dreamland one of its many
nicknames is a magnet for civilian
Watchdogs Aerospace enthusiasts the UFO
curious and most likely spies we see
flying oval rates quite frequently York
are new a naturalized citizen has
devoted much of his life to
understanding the base his website
dreamlandresort.com is a Clearinghouse
for all things 51 including photos and
videos of the base and anything flying
above it
[Music]
arnu owns a home in Las Vegas but bought
a place in tiny Rachel Nevada so he
could be close to the action I came to
this country
because I love this country and I became
a citizen to support this country I
would never do anything to hurt this
country but I don't understand what is
going on right now our new is not
anti-government not even anti-syncrasy
he says he's always been careful to
screen out content that might cross the
line and expose something that is
legitimately classified but on November
3rd he learned the hard way that
something on his site had apparently
gone too far more than a dozen Agents
from the FBI and Air Force OSI smashed
through his gate broke through his door
and stormed into his home I'm asking
okay what is going on what are you doing
in my house
um
to which I just I'm looking basically at
this point at a riot shield and a gun
that was drawn and pointed at me and an
agent uh in a Stern voice giving me
commands to turn around hands against
the wall
uh the event proceeded to yank my hands
pretty violently back uh handcuffed me
very tight I mean it really hurt I got
the message that hey these guys are
serious arnu was held outside while
agents searched the home he was given a
few pages from a search warrant that was
more than 40 pages long most of the
warrant remained sealed he says
including what he presumes is an
explanation of what the agents wanted as
it is right now I have no key
understanding what I'm being charged
with or why my property was seen was
seized
my various computers three or four
laptops
cell phones memory sticks backup drives
my camera equipment that is worth almost
ten thousand dollars by drone everything
was taken I was presented with a list of
items that were taken but not with the
reason why they were taken at the same
time another team of more than a dozen
agents kicked in the door of his Las
Vegas residence roused it and detained
his girlfriend and then conducted
another vigorous search as she got out
of bed in her underwear no shoes on
Barefoot she was laid out into the
street in the middle of the street in
full view of all the neighbors and
subsequently our homes were searched
arnu says he repeatedly asked what he
had done and received hints from an
agent at one or more images on his site
showed something that's classified but
no one will tell him what it is or which
image crossed the line he voluntarily
took down some panoramas of the base and
said he would have quietly done so
earlier if anyone had requested it flash
back to three years ago went up to two
million online UFO enthusiasts bowed to
storm into area 51. arnu led the local
campaign to discourage the event even
defended the Air Force's need for some
secrecy many of the people who gather on
his website are former Area 51 employees
or government contractors not
anti-government radicals do you feel
that this was sending some sort of a
message to you that hey Area 51 is still
a classified Place secret things go on
there sensitive things go on there and
you better watch your step I believe
this was all about sending a message
arnu will be meeting with an attorney
this week we'll try to arrange for a
return of his belongings he does not
know if he might be facing criminal
charges